ouais ben bada en l'arrestation de
monsieur applebaum évidemment ne passe
pas inaperçue même la presse
internationale s'est intéressé à son cas
où la presse internationale parfois des
pays mêmes acl lointain je vais vous
donner un chiffre d'influencé
communication la fille est une firme qui
est de relations publiques et qui est
spécialisé dans les médias eux ils ont
répertorié une quinzaine de pays qui ont
parlé de l'arrestation du maire de
montréal michael applebaum
évidemment tous ces médias là on peut
envoyer leurs journalistes ici à
montréal ils ont repris les informations
de radio canada par exemple ou des
diverses agences de presse vous avez ici
à detroit on en a on a commencé on a
parlé on a fait un article sur
l'arrestation du maire à ce quotidien
belge aussi en néerlandais qui nous
parlent ou peuvent deviner de
l'arrestation du maire de montréal ou
encore ce quotidien de l'himalaya 2 et
marine times qui relate l'arrestation du
maire et qui reprend une dépêche de
reuters et qu'il met enfin en contexte
en expliquant qu' un autre maire de
montréal gérald tremblay avait dû
démissionner il ya quelques mois presstv
la chaîne d'état en anglais de l'iran a
relaté l'arrestation du maire aussi
presstv qui relate souvent les
informations qui sont qui donna un peu
une mauvaise image au canada étant donné
les relations plutôt délétère entre le
canada et l'iran enfin le quotidien
israélien de times au visuel qui en a
parlé un titre aussi intéressant celui
du atlantic wire un magazine qui est
nous dit mais qu'est ce qui ne va pas
avec les maires du canada point
d'interrogation
et enfin il ya aussi des réactions tout
près de chez nous à montréal notre
journaliste les lillois vert est allé à
la taverne chez mag nom qui est connu
ici à montréal on y parle très souvent
de politique elle a demandé aux gens ce
qu'ils en pensaient une citation de
fernand marcotte qui nous dit l ancien
maire on l'a critiqué mais il n'était
peut-être pas coupable donc des gens qui
s'interrogent aussi sur la culpabilité
ou l'innocence de michael a pas bon bado
remercie beaucoup
merci à vous et à plus tard pour voir la
suite